maybe for you there's a tomorrow maybe
there's 1,000 or 10 but for some of us
there's only today hey sexy get in
I believe high school's almost over
nice we didn't write you know kiss the
hottest boys went to the stickiest
parties have a big party later
my mom's going out of town oh my god
what's she doing her what this there's
all high school things just mommy said
you have to get up Saturday maybe for
you there's a tomorrow what happened
last night
what are you talking about
and having deja vu all day long is all
high school things just a blip watch out
for the truck what trap
regardless of anything I do or say the
day starts and ends the same my mom's
going on in China status you're having a
party yeah how'd you know
jean-robert I'm M freaking out are you
in trouble you can trust me
huh do you think I'm a good person
it doesn't matter what I think sorting
is what you think so say path 12 o'clock
why do I hate Juliet why do you care all
of a sudden yesterday you said you were
afraid she would bite you that was a
long time ago that was yesterday
if I was going to relive the same day
over and over
I want it to be all day and that would
make a difference
not just for me they just need to hold
on for one more minute
I could wake me now
you